Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
Today, we're going to do another
fun problem that has
to do with a random number
of coin flips.
So the experiment we're going
to run is as follows.
We're given a fair six-sided
die, and we roll it.
And then we take a fair coin,
and we flip it the number of
times indicated by the die.
That is to say, if I roll a four
on my die, then I flip
the coin four times.
And then we're interested in
some statistics regarding the
number of heads that show
up in our sequence.
In particular, we want to
compute the expectation and
the variance of the number
of heads that we see.
So the first step of this
problem is to translate the
English to the math.
So we have to define
some notation.
I went ahead and did
that for us.
I defined n to be the outcome
of the die role.
Now, since we flip the coin the
number of times shown by
the die roll, n is equivalently
the number of
flips that we perform.
And n, of course, is a random
variable, and I've written its
PMF up here.
So Pn of n is just a discrete
uniform random variable
between 1 and 6, because we're
told that the die has six
sides and that it's fair.
Now, I also defined h
to be the number of
heads that we see.
So that's the quantity
of interest.
And it turns out that Bernoulli
random variables
will be very helpful to
us in this problem.
So I defined x sub i as
1 if the ith flip is
heads, and 0 otherwise.
And what we're going to do now
is, we're going to use these x
sub i's to come up with
an expression for h.
So if you want to count the
number of heads, one possible
thing you could do is start with
0 and then look at the
first coin flip.
If it's heads, you add 1 to 0,
which I'm going to call your
running sum.
If the first flip is
tails, you add 0.
And similarly, after that, after
every trial, if you see
heads, you add 1 to
your running sum.
If you see a tails, you add 0.
And in that way, we can
precisely compute h.
So the mathematical statement of
what I just said is that h
is equal to x1 plus x2
plus x3, all the way
through x sub n.
So now, we are interested
in computing e of h, the
expectation of h.
So your knee jerk reaction might
be to say, oh, well, by
linearity of expectation,
we know that this is an
expectation of x1, et cetera
through the expectation of xn.
But in this case, you would
actually be wrong.
Don't do that.
And the reason that this is not
going to work for us is
because we're dealing
with a random
number of random variables.
So each xi is a random
variable.
And we have capital n of them.
But capital n is a
random variable.
It denotes the outcome
of our die roll.
So we actually cannot just
take the sum of these
expectations.
Instead, we're going to have
to condition on n and use
iterated expectation.
So this is the mathematical
statement of what I just said.
And the reason why this works
is because conditioning on n
will take us to the case that
we already know how to deal
with, where we have a known
number of random variables.
And of course, iterated
expectations holds, as you saw
in lecture.
I will briefly mention here that
the formula we're going
to derive is derived
in the book.
And it was probably derived
in lecture.
So if you want, you can just
go to that formula
immediately.
But I think the derivation of
the formula that we need is
quick and is helpful.
So I'm going to go through
it quickly.
Let's do it over here.
Plugging in our running
sum for h, we get this
expression--
x1 plus x2 et cetera plus
xn, conditioned on n.
And this, of course,
is n times the
expectation of x sub i.
So again, I'm going through
this quickly,
because it's in the book.
But this step holds, because
each of these xi's have the
same statistics.
They're all Bernoulli with
parameter of 1/2, because our
coin is fair.
And so I used x sub i to say it
doesn't really matter which
integer you pick for i, because
the expectation of xi
is the same for all i.
So this now, the expectation
of x sub i, this is just a
number, it's just some constant,
so you can pull it
out of the expectation.
So you get the expectation
of x sub i times the
expectation of n.
So I gave away the answer
to this a second ago.
But x sub i is just a Bernoulli
random variable with
parameter of success of 1/2.
And we know already that the
expectation of such a random
variable is just p, or 1/2.
So this is 1/2 times
expectation of n.
And now n we know is a discrete
uniform random variable.
And there's a formula that I'm
going to use, which hopefully
some of you may remember.
If you have a discrete uniform
random variable that takes on
values between a and b--
let's use w--
if you call this random variable
w, then we have that
the variance of w is equal to b
minus a times b minus a plus
2 divided by 12.
So that's the variance.
We don't actually need the
variance, but we will need
this later.
And the expectation of w--
actually, let's just
do it up here right
ahead for this problem.
Because we have a discrete
uniform random variable, the
expectation is just
the middle.
So you agree hopefully that the
middle is right at 3.5,
which is also 7/2.
So this is times 7/2, which
is equal to 7/4.
So we are done with
part of part a.
I'm going to write this answer
over here, so I can erase.
And we're going to do something
very similar to
compute the variance.
To compute the variance,
we are going to also
condition on n.
So we get rid of this source
of randomness.
And then we're going to use law
of total variance, which
you've also seen in lecture.
And again, the formula
for this variance is
derived in the book.
So I'm going to go through
it quickly.
But make sure you understand
this derivation, because it
exercises a lot of stuff
we taught you.
So this, just using law of
total variance, is the
variance of expectation of h
given n, plus the expectation
of the variance of h given n.
And now, plugging in
this running sum
for h, you get this.
It's a mouthful to write.
Bear with me.
x1 through xn given n--
so I didn't do anything fancy.
I just plugged this into here.
So this term is similar
to what we saw
in a previous problem.
By linearity of expectation and
due to the fact that all
of the x i's are distributed in
the same way, they have the
same expectation, this
becomes n times the
expectation of x sub i.
And let's do this
term over here.
This term--
well, conditioned on
n, this n is known.
So we essentially have
a finite known sum of
independent random variables.
We know that the variance of
a sum of independent random
variables is the sum
of the variances.
So this is the variance of x1
plus the variance of x2 et
cetera, plus the
variance of xn.
And furthermore, again, because
all of these xi's have
the same distribution, the
variance is the same.
So we can actually write this
as n times the variance of x
sub i, where x sub i
just corresponds
to one of the trials.
It doesn't matter which one,
because they all have the same
variance and expectation.
So now, we're almost
home free.
This is just some scaler.
So we can take it out of
the variance, but we
have to square it.
So this becomes expectation
of xi squared times
the variance of n.
And then this variance is also
just a scalar, so we can take
it outside.
So then we get variance of x sub
i times expectation of n.
Now, we know that the
expectation of x sub i is just
the probability of success,
which is 1/2.
So we have 1/2 squared, or 1/4,
times the variance of n.
So that's where this formula
comes in handy.
b is equal to 6, a
is equal to 1.
So we get that the variance
of n is equal to 5 times--
and then 5 plus 2 is 7--
divided by 12.
So this is just a formula from
the book that you guys
hopefully remember.
So we get 35/12.
And then the variance of xi,
we know the variance of a
Bernoulli random variable is
just p times 1 minus p.
So in our case, that's 1/2
times 1/2, which is 1/4.
So we get 1/4.
And then the expectation of n,
we remember from our previous
computation, is just 7/2.
So I will let you guys do this
arithmetic on your own time.
But the answer comes
out to be 77/48.
So I will go ahead and put
our answer over here--
77/48--
so that I can erase.
So I want you guys to
start thinking about
part b while I erase.
Essentially, you do the same
experiment that we did in part
a, except now we use two
dice instead of one.
So in part b, just to repeat,
you now have two dice.
You roll them.
You look at the outcome.
If you have an outcome of four
on one die and six on another
die, then you flip the
coin 10 times.
So it's the same exact
experiment.
We're interested in the number
of heads we want the
expectation and the variance.
But this step is now a
little bit different.
Again, let's approach this by
defining some notation first.
Now, I want to let n1 be the
outcome of the first die.
And then you can let n2 be the
outcome of the second die.
And we'll start with
just that.
So one way you could approach
this problem is say, OK, if n1
is the outcome of my first die
and n2 is the outcome of my
second die, then the number of
coin flips that I'm going to
make is n1 plus n2.
This is the total coin flips.
So you could just repeat the
same exact math that we did in
part a, except everywhere that
you see an n, you replace that
n with n1 plus n2.
So that will get you to your
answer, but it will require
slightly more work.
We're going to think about
this problem slightly
differently.
So the way we are thinking about
it just now, we roll two
dice at the same time.
We add the results
of the die rolls.
And then we flip the coin
that number of times.
But another way you can think
about this is, you roll one
die, and then you flip the coin
the number of times shown
by that die and count
the number of heads.
And then you take the second
die and you roll it.
And then you flip the coin that
many more times and count
the number of heads
after that.
So you could define h1 to be
number of heads in the first
n1 coin flips.
And you could just let h2 be
the number of heads in the
last n2 coin flips.
So hopefully that terminology
is not confusing you.
Essentially, what I'm saying
is, n1 plus n2 means you'll
have n1 flips, followed by
n2 flips, for a total
of n1 plus n2 flips.
And then within the first n1
flips, you can get some number
of heads, which we're
calling h1.
And in the last n2 flips, you
can get some number of heads,
which is h2.
So the total number of heads
that we get at the end--
I'm going to call it h star--
is equal to h1 plus h2.
And what part b is really
asking us for is the
expectation of h star and
the variance of h star.
But here's where something
really beautiful happens.
h1 and h2 are independent,
and they are
statistically the same.
So the reason why they're
independent is because--
well, first of all, all of our
coin flips are independent.
And they're statistically the
same, because the experiment
is exactly the same.
And everything's independent.
So instead of imagining one
person rolling two die and
then summing the outcomes and
flipping a coin that many
times and counting heads, you
can imagine one person takes
one die and goes
into one room.
A second person takes a
second die and goes
into another room.
They run their experiments.
Then they report back
to a third person
the number of heads.
And that person adds them
together to get h star.
And in that scenario, everything
is very clearly
independent.
So the expectation of h star--
you actually don't need
independence for this part,
because linearly of expectation
always holds.
But you get the expectation of
h1 plus the expectation of h2.
And because these guys are
statistically equivalent, this
is just two times the
expectation of h.
And the expectation of h we
calculated in part a.
So this is 2 times 7 over 4.
Now, for the variance,
here's where the
independence comes in.
I'm actually going to write this
somewhere where I don't
have to bend over.
So the variance of h star is
equal to the variance of h1
plus the variance of
h2 by independence.
And that's equal to 2 times
the variance of h, because
they are statistically
the same.
And the variance of h
we computed already.
So this is just 2 times
77 over 48.
So the succient answer to part
b is that both the mean and
the variance double from part
A. So hopefully you guys
enjoyed this problem.
We covered a bunch of things.
So we saw how to deal with
having a random number of
random variables.
Usually we have a fixed number
of random variables.
In this problem, the number of
random variables we were
adding together was
itself random.
So to handle that, we
conditioned on n.
And to compute expectation, we
use iterated expectation.
To compute variance, we used
law of total variance.
And then in part b, we were
just a little bit clever.
We thought about how can we
reinterpret this experiment to
reduce computation.
And we realized that part b is
essentially two independent
trials of part a.
So both the mean and the
variance should double.